mon personnage de comédie c'est un
personnage qu'on peut résumer en un
adjectif
car vous prenez molière c'est navarre
c'est bon je suis ciom c'est une figure
le radin le fou toute la finesse ici et
dans l'idée de connaître de façon assez
basique un seul adjectif à une seule
typologie c'est exactement à l'opposé
d'un personnage classique de films
classiques ou de séries classiques où on
va chercher des couches et on met des
couches des couches c'est chouette aussi
de se retrouver comme ça entre filles
nach ndaw shepard et là c'est vrai que
oui il ya la fille parfaite il ya la
dengue il ya la fille qui en fait est un
garçon il ya la vieille la nymphomane la
secure émotivement la lesbienne
invisible
ouais mais comme comme il le faudrait
arrêter un cirque ilya et dès qu'ils
comprennent le traîne un candidat ils
vont tous et ils vont le mettre en avant
ils vont monter d'une certaine manière
pour qu'on voit que ce trail axes de
cette personne et c'est donc au final
c'était des caractéristiques simple mais
qui laissait une grande liberté aux
filles de pouvoir mettre à jouer
d'autres couches et bien écoute on se
rejoint l'intérieur je te voilà ty pas
qu'elle essaie de faire des vagues -
qu'est-ce que c'est une mini vans quand
même moi je ne sais pas
mater baldé pour sa caisse du excellent
excellent ce soir on a tourné où on
arrivait dans le mon aventure
attend sur cet essai la
ola voilà oui ces majors voilà
je m'appelle et me dit on va tu connais
l'expression l'amour rend aveugle eh ben
je me suis pas d'accord je sais que
c'est pas évident tout y est
eh bien on se voit à l'intérieur oui
enfin moi je ne te dirai pas à
l'intérieur le vrai défi le saas est
différent essayé de retranscrire la
sensation qu'on a nous mêmes en tant que
spectateur quand on voit ces gens là
quand on les voit faire dans les télé
réalité c'est à dire on sent que c'est
la première fois les premières
sensations
tu vois qu'il ya cette émotion de la
rencontre et ça c'est important pour
nous que ce soit le plus réaliste
possible tout en étant drôle mais qu'on
ait cette même sensation de wau
qu'est-ce qui vous nous dire quel est ce
que ça va marcher car les accessoires
j'adore comment elle se présente parce
que dans l'été dans les télé réalités
dans le match heures
c'est fou ce qu'elles font et fille
quand elle se présente y en a qui
présente des spectacles
dakar avec des citations qu'arrivant
l'armée en a qui arrivent donc céphalées
qui cette même richesse
[Applaudissements]
ça fait une hyper marrant parce que
c'étaient toutes les filles je faisais
le rend leur entrée ça à soi un peu nos
persos chat a l'air essai de giteau hier
damien
les salaires en revanche je te fais un
petit cadeau je me souvient m comme marc
non mais c'est génial c'était
exceptionnel c'est d'un coup
j'apparaissais de nulle part sortie du
bateau avec mon talent je faisais mon
show sur le tapis rouge
qu'elle est belle oh quelle femme
bonsoir je m'appelle sahara et je suis
je suis plein de vie sahara est la très
très envie de participer à ce jeu parce
qu'elle a très envie de rencontrer
l'homme de sa vie et tu préfères que la
vie se soit plus tonifie et ou plus
précisément un père pour son futur en
form vi et féminins ont dit qu une vie
plutôt chi à la ronde et sonates
d'accord une vis à vis invités à vis et
un vie ont dit un oui pardon
est passé pour un court pas moi ce qui
me fait rire en général c'est quand je
vois des traits de caractère un peu
un peu surligner
valérie à valérie pas si elle est
stressée c'est comme ça qu'elle est
définie dans le scénario et les très
émotive ou j'espère que ça va aller ça
inquiète pas on se retrouve dans la
villa
les avantages de ton mec des comédiennes
de deux aussi forte c'est que
baltes amène un truc enfin la tête à l
t'amène une magie à des endroits qui qui
avait fait qu'il n'existait pas et c'est
vraiment pour le coup il n'y a pas de
direction d'acteurs là dessus c'est l
absence j'avoue que mon lait 100g comme
tout le monde un peu le truc dans
l'imaginaire de manger des poux etc mais
je connaissais pas plus que ça vainqueur
de singe et moi j'ai un coeur
d'artichaut
vraiment qu'airbus doit par un amateur
de la villa à adam dans la ville à
l'intérieur donc j'ai regardé wade
documentaire soit jane sur notre
physique sous chanteuse et des trucs
pour enfants tu pouvais aussi regarder
avec nos cuisses planète et ouais c'est
plus un truc d'observation qu'autre
chose
les parties
alors racontez moi un peu votre histoire
vous venez d'où ce alors
même avec le casting qu'on a on voit le
personnage plus que plus que le guest
qui est venu faire très très dans
l'épisode 1 on dit ah [ __ ] il ya na li
na na na est en fait très vite ça
devient les personnages et on rentre
dedans ça je trouve effectivement c'est
un truc qu'on a on a réussi mais parce
que l'on a on a travaillé en amont avec
les comédiennes en ce qu'était une
magnifique c'est que c'est un jeu latin
jérémy nous faire une impro une sorte
d'audit sion des personnages en fait on
leur disait ben voila tu es valérie tu
viens de lyon a pris le train pour bien
passer le casting pour la femme ce que
tu change vraiment l'amour est en fait
donc elle sortait de la salle on
attendait on filmait elle tapait à la
porte on joue elle est vraiment les
directeurs de casting de la de
l'émission valérie sa série à leur poser
des questions dit voilà pourquoi tu
cherche l'amour pourquoi c'est quoi tu
es toi c'est quoi ton travail idéales
cecchini c'est important pour moi de
faire ça ce que je rêverais de livres en
tant qu'acteur c'est génial de mettre
les gens conditions des personnages très
très vite et d'improviser dessus pour
que le personnage jaillissent de
lui-même je souhaite une belle vie
marque une belle vie de merde